[Music]
[Applause]
yeah great will ferrell actor comedian
and a long time la sports fan
he's
[Applause]
he is
he is
all in with the bangles
i will
uh got some face paint there
uh homage to you my friend
back in the day back in the day i did
that remember i lost the bed yeah i lost
the bet and i had to do that and i had
to roar yeah
every before i spoke every time i'd have
to go roar so anyway i think the yankees
should
so
explain your bet that you lost because
will will's a a great listener of the
show we appreciate that i didn't know
you'd come in dressed as uh well a
bengal if you recall last time i was
here
i got here so early yes
for my hair and makeup yeah
and you guys were speculating like what
is he doing why did he get here so early
yeah and you guys were like oh he's
going to come out as this person or
mugatu or this and that and i came out
just as normal will ferrell
and uh
devastatingly disappointed you the looks
on your faces i'm like
god next time you guys are back i'm
bringing the heat well i didn't know it
took you that long just to look like
wilford
it doesn't i just i'm very conscientious
okay you know la traffic
yeah
are you going to wear this home to the
family
uh
i haven't even thought that far okay
just
thank you yeah one time did you see that
patch on is it says bobby gritsch how
great is that got a bobby griffin of
course
yeah yeah uh how long have you owned
that you know when you think of super
bowl yeah
i think you
dressed like a tiger and bobby bobby
rich
it's good to see you by the way i'm
pulling for the rams no um
are you a rams fan i'm not i'm i was
back in the day when i was a kid and
then they broke my heart and left
oh so you can't fall back in love i
can't i can't fall back in love
are you pulling for the bengals i i am i
i'm really liking the the the joe the
joe uh borough kid are you gonna go to
the game
i'm going to the game are you bringing
the family to the guy no
no way
i don't know
i gotta be able to move in and out yeah
you gotta stealth yeah uh but weren't
you you guys were coming up with uh
listen to the show i'm coming off kind
of pathetic here how much i listened to
right we wondered like what your life is
like will because you you don't do
anything do you weren't you guys coming
up with nicknames for joe yes
right yeah
we came with up with joe ohio okay
i couldn't take joe cool because that's
joe montana that's not fair
i thought of sloppy joe burrow sloppy
everyone loves sloppy joes yeah had you
guys landed on sloppy joe well
no because then i'm glad i bought the
dot-com
you got the domain i got the domain
okay but it that kind of means he had a
bad game or they lost
like in defeat he could be sloppy joe
okay maybe how much did you think this
through
i just was trying to connect joe
was trying to connect wheelboro
joe wheelbarrow
i was really it's a tough one i like
wheels sparrow better than i do
was this always a love seat
um it was a single chair but it's a
single chair yeah before yeah but i
brought in uh it's it's called love sack
it is after the b-52 song that's
love shaq yeah yeah but that's that
that's the brand it's called love songs
that's love sack yes
yeah are you guys pushing love sex yes
we have sofas yeah it's a it's a it's a
sactional
okay no it is oh yeah no i'm not i'm not
disputing it i'm not disputing it do you
want me to get you one i i i'm good
uh i i didn't get through my full intro
though all eight episodes of the limited
series the shrink next door available
now on apple tv plus yes
is it all available dark comedy
it's a dark
would you say it's got i don't know
i would say you put it in the dark
comedy category but it's um
it's a little more dramatic draw yeah
it's a little more drama than the
uh capital d r a m a lowercase d y okay
dramady okay
are you now a serious actor
uh
i'm here to announce on the dan patrick
show
that
[Laughter]
serious acting oh really so you retired
from comedy done from comedy wow well
it's a great run
it's a great run great great great run
uh what's going to be your first serious
acting role
uh i'm
i'm going to
reprise the tiger king
um
in a
very heart-wrenching drama okay yeah and
you'll play
i'll play uh uh
uh what's-her-face carol bass yes
yeah
wait i think somebody's already done no
they're already doing it okay yeah all
right
uh the danette said look can we ask one
question each
okay i'm gonna let you decide
now this didn't work out with kevin
costner
uh paulie in what way insulted oh really
and costner didn't have a sense of humor
he did he jumped on paulie
and used the f word
he did
yeah he got f-bomb bike
yeah bucket list yeah that's i was going
to say that's a badge of honor well i
asked him the question because kevin
coster at one time i think was the
biggest actor in all of hollywood that's
fair to say i would think so and i said
when you were at your peak after uh
untouchables and all those movies
already yeah yeah
yeah see already troubled waters yeah
yeah yeah yeah
if paulie said that to you what would
you say
uh
i i would i'd say keep going
yeah oh you wouldn't f-bomb him no no no
no no okay no but costner's a serious
actor
serious actor but i'm about to
transition into that so and then you
would have yeah i would i would
all right
all right you can lead off with your one
question for will farrell okay i don't
understand anything about how movies are
made but let's say you're in old school
or whatever comedy you're making and
you're one of the actors if you nail a
scene a take of a scene
can you lobby for that scene to be put
in the movie and how does that work
uh
lobby for the scene to get the movie
let's see
eight takes of the scene
i listened to the dvd of uh old school
and when you were walking down the
stairs in the sweater vest you did the
sneeze
the side sneeze and vince vaughn was
like that's such a sneaky little joke
and he loved it but when you if you have
a take where you think you nailed it or
it's a funny little uh ad-lib you can
you can uh
what they'll do is uh circle circle the
the takes so you watch it and the
director will be like circle that one so
you can double back if i if i watch the
cut of the movie i'll go i i think i did
something weird a couple and they can
they can double back and put it in if
the director's listening to you
sometimes they are and sometimes they're
not
usually they are okay but you're with my
status
don't listen to me seating you're on
your one question my question for will
is um which winter olympic sport do you
believe you would excel in most
whoa
probably
probably
either bobsled or luge would you do uh
lose your skeleton
face first feet first oh i i would do
luge i'm not going to do skeleton but
you
skeleton's
face face first yeah i wouldn't do the
face first i don't think um
because i have i have incredible core
strength
well when i think incredible inner thigh
yeah because you i think you do all this
yeah
right yeah would you be front or back in
the bobsled
well what i i i definitely wouldn't be
up front yeah i i wouldn't i'd be one of
the guys pushing in the back i would
think okay all right did you hear our
favorite uh loser
no his name is uh seaman pavalchenko
stephen pavelchenko and then we found
out
he's he's america he's from burbank
he is i think he's from the ukraine and
in
in the ukraine seaman means simon i
think okay
right
so a little sneaky yeah yeah yeah
uh todd your one question for welfare
what was the moment or situation during
your illustrious snl career where you
felt like you know what it's time to i
had enough it's time to move on to the
next chapter of my uh my career so the
moment where i'm like i gotta get out
yeah well you felt like i think it's
time to move on to bigger and better
things i have this on my resume i've
done all i can do how much is it how
much thought did you give this i was
thinking about that was worse than
paulie's question to comment it's a
legitimate question all right well when
did you know you were washed
i should i should
i should walk out at this point no no
i'm sorry
uh
that wasn't meant to be offensive i
don't know yeah i don't know if there
was a moment where i'm like i'm done i
better leave
uh but i i you know
i was on for seven years at a certain
point
i was i thought i better
i better get out now how about because
i'm cause i'm let me
phase
rephrase your your question todd did i
ask that in a way that was that sounded
like offensive
it was meant to be it was meant to be
that i'm i'm ready for to do something
else i've done i've done it at such a
high level and i'm ready for the next
challenge you have to explain your
question that's how it was meant to be
this is a disaster it is it is from
start to finish this is a
when did you realize though
that you'd kind of become
you know in pop culture that you were
more than just somebody who was on
saturday night live that now is
something bigger well
you have to remember saturday night live
being late night tv it's not it's like
it's like dog years seven years equals
like one year of prime time television
if you know if you're the cast of
friends
so many people are watching that after
one or two seasons you're
you become iconic
at the end of seven seasons of saturday
night live people were just now knowing
what my name was when you were washed up
when i was washed up leaving leaving and
they were like good luck pal you're
gonna need it uh
so
but i just i kind of left
i i literally did that show
thinking oh i could just do this for the
rest of my career it's so much fun it's
it's the thing i always wanted to do
but i thought well i'm i'm i'm doing
pretty well right now it's it's now the
good time to leave and test the waters
and
uh
and i kind of it was a real there wasn't
like
20 scripts waiting for me
you know it was it was very much a leap
of faith in the sense of
i had old school that was
in the in the can which is termed
finished finished product
finished in the can
but hadn't come out yet
and then
we had this script about a a human
raised by elves up at the north pole
that was an interesting concept but
needed a lot of work
but that hadn't even been set up yet but
you and so i that was kind of
i just i just thought for better for
worse i'm gonna i'm gonna leave the show
and see what happens but did you have a
sense though when you're leaving that
old school
was your career sort of riding on old
school success
a little bit and it had been uh
it was originally supposed to come out
in november and then it got pushed
to february which is usually not a good
sign when they hold on to a movie and
uh
and so yeah yeah it was it was it was
definitely a leap of faith but and then
elf you've talked about where you
thought you might have made the biggest
mistake of your life yeah yeah yeah yeah
in the uh in the yellow tights sitting
alone in my trailer
but just
just looking in the mirror going
[Laughter]
huh
what else can i do
when this
all goes downhill
i can't imagine of you
sitting in your double banger yeah in my
double and it was and it was not even
and you're in costume i'm in costume all
by yourself with a little tiny you know
a little tiny electric heater
at my feet because it was freezing
you know december in new york and uh but
what did when did you know that that was
because you get james khan yeah
and you had some really interesting john
dinklage was fairly confident throughout
the whole process
and
but it wasn't you know
i i'm sure
sandler's talked about i'm sure you've
had a lot of actors talk about like you
don't know until you're sitting in with
the audience watching the film oh so
even after yeah and just sitting in that
first preview
and you're you're
you know it's an intense opening night
how nervous though
are you
pretty ner i'm not nervous anymore when
i when i'm at these test screens but it
was yeah you you have butterflies in
your stomach and but we can't think of
christmas without elf now
you i mean there's you it's in there
with you can't like if you're full
i'll sue you but you got it's a
wonderful life sure you got ralphie
christmas story yep elf
uh
booty call
one of the classic christmas movies
booty call three booty call three
uh
no i'm very lucky to to have uh
you know it's very rare to have
something that people watch again and
again and yet you know have it land
around christmas okay pretty cool i know
you went through all of this trouble to
put the makeup on yes can you do you
want to come back with us it looks
pretty good it does it's gonna lie it um
i wonder how
long
i wonder if i could spend the rest of my
week in this makeup and just see it how
how
crazy people thought it was so if you
just you know slept on your back yep
and you
you took
just like that yeah
you know walk in to get coffee at
starbucks what's this called again
that's a love
that's lovesack
that's the sanctional slept upright in
this
love section yeah yeah uh
can you can you come back with us or um
what do you think should i come back i
really john's got another question okay
i'll come back
okay all right we'll we'll come back
with will ferrell after this when you
say what do you ever say yeah
i was trying to make the leap that was
he in person yeah yeah here uh
new york
i was trying to make the case that
taking field of dreams it's a very
dangerous movie he actually agreed but
at the time i clunkingly worded it too
uh your your career is at its peak and i
was like and i knew it and i was like
hoping to blow by it because what did
you say
you can't say that he goes uh oh
it was dangerous because it was a
fantasy movie so i got to tell you one
thing about elf uh my kids love elf and
we were in new york about two and a half
years ago and my daughters were probably
eight and ten at the time and walked
past a coffee shop right and they go dad
we got to do it we got to do it and they
said we do it congratulations and i go
do it fast
and they walked in fast
yeah and they're in new york and they
run it like congratulations you did it
and they're going like this and
everyone's looking like they're
absolutely crazy
the best same reaction in the movie yeah
yeah yeah
they couldn't wait to do it in new york
city they're like dad is this the one
like this is the one and we know it now
that is committing to a role right there
like you sort of want to happen intense
focus right that's that's committed
i i
like we were saying before i didn't
realize it was the whole outfit yeah and
i i had no idea what the bet was but
it's what's funny about clips like these
is they don't even remember like they'll
show back an old clip and i'll be
getting like dan starbucks with my
underwear on outside of my pants and i'm
like why did i do that you're just in
work mode yeah you're just okay i got
one thing i wasn't looking at your groin
but what's the belt
this is a
wow
ron
it was just a a gift
closer my wardrobe my wardrobe friend
and she was like i found this wrong belt
so for people who get the reference
great if you don't yeah then i've just
got a belt that says wrong i just think
you're wrong
there goes wrong
it's this little subtle okay yeah
accent normally wardrobe doesn't let you
take things like you don't did you take
anything from any movie are you allowed
to do that the fire ship didn't you tell
us the fire season i've got mine well
you've got ron burke i got my my i got
uh the the flint tropics uniform from
semi-pro
i've got a ron burgundy outfit i've got
a skating outfit from blades of glory
[Music]
you would never know that he's a serious
actor now the way he's dressed today
bengal's super fan will ferrell staying
with us uh you can see him in the shrimp
go galls
pingles
us bengals the real bengals fan no you
just shorten it to gulls
yeah the shrink next door is available
now on apple tv plus so uh will is in
there with uh paul rudd and it's a kind
of a serious turn yeah yeah yeah and
you've gone seriously there's some
laughs there's some laughs through the
tears but it's it's it's it's serious
can you cry on cue
um when fritz he asks me questions yes
when he breaks me down
i can't cry on i can't cry on cue
well you did for my uh my sp your speech
for me for the uh radio hall of fame
yeah i well cause i really
yeah that one was easy because of the
emotion of the moment
everybody what was the rea by the way
we didn't talk since no he didn't um so
i asked will
to
kind of help and duck me into the radio
and you said and he said don't don't be
afraid to get emotional yes
yes
and it's so we're in chicago this is uh
back in october and and uh
will just did a video and i didn't want
to let anybody know everybody else is
doing these heartfelt you know intros
for this person who's going into the
radio hall of fame and then will just
got up there and
started
saying i basically wasn't going to
amount to anybody anything and everybody
knew that and then uh the tears came
artificial tears how how did the radio
hall of fame people react to my my level
of they loved it okay they they loved it
yeah they did they had a good sense of
humor yeah but that's when you started
to transition into a serious actor it
felt like that was the moment
yeah
could you do something if i said um
like the
[Music]
taxi driver
right are you like mentally can you get
into a roll like that a bad guy where
you go
something deep and dark like that well i
kind of had to do it in shrink there
there are pretty powerful moments where
you know uh paul rudd who plays the
therapist uh um
who is kind of controlling
marty's life is
very manipulative throughout this this
whole series and
he kind of you know
push there's a push-pull going on where
he
you know he gives me encouragement and
then he makes me feel horrible and those
moments were incredibly real and
it didn't he was so effective and so
mean
that it was not it was not hard to get
to that anxious place and uh
and before i knew it i i'm
i'm crying which is a very surreal
in front of a crew of 50 people and you
have to cry
on cue but it it it's funny how you get
yourself into that space and it it's
just happening what's the role that you
brought home
um
in terms of like i couldn't shake that
character
uh
i
i haven't done
i don't think i've done so many things
where i'm like
you know
you only have to talk please don't speak
to me as well talk to the character
uh i'm pretty good about shaking it off
when you're not a daniel day lewis i'm
not a daniel day now okay i'm not a dad
but i do i did uh take a year off and
study shoemaking in italy okay yes okay
just like daniel dave lewiston
shoe cobbling sorry but but you're not
cobbler yeah you're not ron burgundy at
home no
no no no no my wife would kill me i was
gonna say did you want to be ron
burgundy at home
yeah
um has your wife ever said sometimes
when we make love though
hello honey
i'm now going to lay upon you
scotch
we are now beginning what is called love
making session it's gonna last exactly
seven and a half minutes
we're beginning
do you even drink scotch
i'll have i'll have scotch on occasion
sure
like if you're gonna tie one on with us
tonight right
in venice yeah
is it venice or marina del rey well i'm
getting into that piece of information
well if we're going to party we're going
to yes of course yeah
what are you drinking
uh you know all
anything from an ipa enjoy a good ipa
who doesn't
right
i could you're acting like i'm crazy no
it's just like it's hard to take you
seriously
paint on your face
maybe a
a tequila inspired drink okay um when's
the last time you were drunk
i'm trying to remember
like like slurring drunk
yeah not blackout drunk
like just like wow
well looks like he's tipsy
i don't
my tolerance isn't
what it is what it used to be
uh so i do find myself even after say
three glasses of wine okay sometimes but
it's saturday night live did you party
we would uh
pretty much every wednesday after the
read-through we tie one on you'd get
after it until three and three or four
in the morning yeah
and then then you got the after party
on uh saturday night to the sunday
morning is that mandatory that you have
to show up in it's not mandatory but you
you just
it was so much fun you'd stay until
five six in the morning
and uh
you know
hang out with the guys from the strokes
[Laughter]
i never did
but other people told me about it
he is will ferrell uh all episodes of
the uh
i did see christopher walken crawl out
of a party once crawl crawl
but didn't he show up in that the famous
uh he showed up a party and he had
kittens
he had a coat shy mcbride told us that
he showed up at a dinner party he had um
a a coat and he had kittens oh i don't
remember that
and he said i don't remember i've got
kittens oh kittens
i just remember talking the first time
he hosted i remember i remember talking
to him and going gosh chris so fun to
watch you work you're just so funny he's
like really
because i have no idea
oh cause well keep doing it because it's
just
everything you say is just it doesn't
matter what we write for you it's just
so funny
the limited time i have no idea is the
shrink next door available on apple tv
plus great to see you uh
we're up against a break are you guys
going to sofi will you be there
no
all right no i you can come to my house
but i won't be
i'll be at so far